a 1963 Ferrari 250 GTO
it sold for 52 million dollars last year
making it the most expensive car in the
world it's one of dozens of Ferraris
designed right here at Pininfarina 's
headquarters in the northwest of italy
where the relationship with Ferrari
produced a number of cars a fan tag with
fantastic design me that my father has
been working on more than 100 models
it's a legacy that very nearly didn't
continue Pininfarina struck real trouble
five years ago along with the rest of
the European auto market it shed
hundreds of workers restructured its
debt and was forced to look elsewhere
for revenue only this year will it
return to profit milling architecture
seems to be very promising
it is the right expression for a
long-lasting durable elegant design so
it is a very much promising for the
future the firm's luxury apartment tower
in Singapore bears the same curves that
seemed most at home on a Ferrari those
curves are in Pininfarina x' design DNA
spot them here on a trophy for a Dubai
cycling event and here on its latest
creation the camión open since not a pen
is not a pain so is there forever so
this instrument you can you can draw you
can sketch you can write and neighbors
go out the pen pencil Hybrid has a tip
made of ether graph an alloy that leaves
a mark on paper
much like the graphite tip of a pencil
except it can't be erased we are a crazy
for these days we are lovers and I mean
we put a lot of passion in every thing
we do from a macro point of view and
micro we must never stop to innovate
first of all to explore new areas
staying close with the quality and
excellence if there is something that we
should do it on Esther years is to go
back to the roots even more design has
to be emotional and has to bring a
strong personality to the product or if
you have designed 50 successful car and
then you are starting project 51 you
turn the clock to zero and you start
again like it was the first patriarch of
the clan and chairman of the company
that bears his name
Paolo Pininfarina has extraordinarily
big shoes to fill the secret is they
never take for granted what has been
done the design firm was founded by
Batista Farina known as pinon in 1930
my grandfather was really a vision or an
inventor because invented the style
invented a brand and invented a family
Batista may have created Pininfarina but
his son Sergio transformed it into a
globally revered brand he led the
company for 40 years and became known as
the godfather of Italian design Sergio
was determined to change the perception
of cars as merely functional he wanted
people to love them we have been quite
clear and through the decades following
this vision punctuality is not enough
for us some of the world's most
beautiful cars were first imagined here
in Pininfarina x' can be our new
headquarters in the northwest of italy
Maseratis BMWs Rolls Royces and of
course Ferrari
the relationship with Ferrari is by far
the most important relation in the
pinnacle in the history open Farina
a dates back to 1952 so it's 62 years
from now this model was named Sergio
after Paolo's father a tribute in the
best way that this company knows how the
Farina is a very special company is a
family business so the history of the
family is the history of the company